cool
so here's the situation trying to get
into
the eu today to the schengen zone
and what was a very easy situation
months ago
well in these corona times not too easy
so currently in key of ukraine and the
reason i'm going
is because way over my visa
i am illegal here and i need to get a
new
visa to be in this country but you have
to leave the country
to go to a foreign consulate to come
back
love do you have the tickets okay
they can't see the american because
americans aren't allowed in the eu
yes i think so so you're not democrat
i get a change at the immigration
because i have to exit on this
good luck here we go
it's uh what three people in line
and that's it in a couple days they're
not gonna allow
any ukrainians into hungary so i i hit
this
perfect timing now as far as my return
flight don't know if that's going to
happen because if no one can fly between
the countries
then will they have the flight going
i got a ballistic kit okay but i i paid
for this
it's the first time i've been in an
airport and it's felt like this
you know maybe somewhere at three in the
morning
but not during the day
it's gonna be a big relief just to get
this
uh new residency permit
uh because in the back your head you're
always like
you know they want you out they can get
you out very easily
here we go this is checking it's quite
empty
duty-free not happening a few people out
there
this is the budapest flight
one of the few flights leaving at this
time and i gotta say one of the
best moves i ever made was getting my
italian
citizenship and i could do so through uh
family bloodlines and it was it was a
process but i did this about 10 years
ago
and if i didn't i'd be in a totally
different situation right now
i wouldn't be able to go into the eu
americans cannot go into the eu
at this point in time bar is closed
restaurant closed
and it does drive home
the reality that [ __ ] can change at any
time
life is short and
don't wait to the end of your of your
life to travel because you might not be
able to
right okay
okay okay my point is
in the states especially it's about
deferring uh you know maybe when you're
retired go to italy or
europe or whatnot and
maybe that's not a possibility this is a
pandemic that's obviously affecting the
world it's not a
um super aggressive pandemic in the
sense that everyone's not
falling over the second they get it
so we're lucky in a way uh but who knows
what this turns into eventually he knows
what comes next and
life is short life is finite not your
normal
check-in process you can see their space
when you're
for the most part
okay
it all sort of made sense until we
packed in
on the bus and then it defeated the
purpose of
social distancing here we are who's here
[Music]
[Music]
okay guys about immigrations here
and i got the camera up i don't want to
have it out there
some guys looking at me in a weird way
okay i'll make this quick
two options one tell the truth and uh
let them know i'm here i have to be here
for a few days
that risks the quarantine 14 days or two
hello okay tell him i'm going straight
through to italy
and uh which isn't the truth um
and then i should probably be able to go
through all right it's been really hard
to get information about
do people need to quarantine or not so
here we are
and camera down
okay guys got through that was uh
extremely
easy like he took the passport
boom in so no quarantine
uh mission accomplished
so far so far here in budapest it's uh
well in the airport
and christie was just saying not many
people wearing
masks not many people worried about
corona so it's interesting seeing the
differences between the countries
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
okay thank you so much
that's it that's it that's all
and now in the streets pretty much
nobody has
a mask on
here we go made it
budapest hungry in this place right here
guys this was
i think around 30 32
with all the fees included
it's pretty much whatever you want
online at this point because not many
travelers obviously
a nice view here and then great this is
perfect for just
just me a few thoughts here
uh end of the journey for today uh
flying in eastern europe well
i wouldn't say it was as romantic or
euphoric as usual
because you know everyone's got masks on
the buses
there's more tension say on the buses
getting onto the plane and off the plane
it was still cool being in the sky i
gotta say i haven't left key of ukraine
since the start of this thing so it was
nice just to see some different things
uh but landing in budapest nobody's
wearing a mask
like none of the workers in the airport
i found that to be interesting security
guards and whatnot most were not wearing
masks
and then i realized what i just did will
not be possible
in two days just
no go in two days people coming in from
ukraine doesn't matter your citizenship
where you're from i think it's you're
either 14 days in quarantine
or you're not or you're getting sent
back
so everything feels short-lived right
now everything
sort of feels on the edge and you can
see how
the information changes very quickly but
governments are very slow
so just trying to understand what was
going on here
was pretty difficult like i honestly
thought i could definitely be in
quarantine
for 14 days or i might have to go just
directly through
to italy uh it was super easy though i
got right through
luckily another thing i call the rental
car company
that i rented the car through i'll have
it in a couple days
through skype so they had no idea what
my number was
and they said peter peter santanilla and
i said yes
how did how did you know that and
that sort of sort of tells you where
we're at with tourism like
what am i one of the only uh
reservations for a car rental right now
and the airbnb selection there's pretty
much anything you want
and so you can you can tell tourism is
hurting for sure
and now i'm not i'm not promoting
tourism here i'm not saying go travel
right now i'm here for a very
logical reason i don't want to be caught
out of the country where i live
you know i don't want to be separated
from my my wife obviously
nobody wants to be separated from their
wife or husband or or relationship
whatever they're in so i'm taking this
what i feel to be a bit of a short
window because things are tightening up
in ukraine and
from the sounds of it they're going to
be tightening up here
uh to take care of this residency permit
stuff
so i'm not telling you to travel i'm not
telling you not to travel that's
you know everyone makes their own
decisions so
that's a journey that's a little journey
here in eastern europe at this very
point in time
and i'll have another video
uh soon don't i'll keep it a surprise
because i actually don't know what it's
going to be yet
love the city haven't been here since
2003 check it out
and we'll see you on the next one